well there are some obvious upsides to
storing classified information on a
private server in your basement but one
of the downsides is that foreign
adversaries could hack it wouldn't be
that hard according to the Daily Caller
news foundation that happened to Hillary
Clinton they say a Chinese owned company
did it and may have had real-time access
to her emails during her tenure as
Secretary of State
the FBI is denying that sort of but the
story is still fluid and confusing and
for some reason a lot of people don't
seem that interested in finding out what
actually happened tom Fitton is in the
business of finding out what happened
he's the president Judicial Watch and he
joins us tonight so tom this seems like
one of those stories and I just want to
be completely clear as we were last
night I don't know the answer I don't
know what happened of course but I do
think it's worth finding out and so I'm
a little bit confused by the confusion
why wouldn't we know conclusively years
later what happened to those emails well
there are a few questions did this
meeting take place as alleged between
officials at the office Director of
National Intelligence and Peter struck
and his colleagues at the FBI and was
there discussion about compromised the
server by Chinese front company right
that it happened that they look into it
that they follow up on it we're not
getting much feedback from the FBI why
would it be hard again you're in the
business of getting government to
divulge things at once to hide so why
would it be so hard to get an answer to
a very simple question like that because
the answer would be embarrassing we know
separately that we went to the FBI we
set up a meeting through Peter struck
because we had evidence that the
Russians had compromised Hillary
Clinton's server our guy met with the
struck steam for four hours they never
followed up on any of it how compelling
was the evidence that you had what was
compelling enough that the person who's
doing it for so have security clearance
thought he had to go to the FBI and tell
them that there might have been a
classified compromised of information by
these Russia type servers and the
document that we had found came from the
same groups of server numbers that were
affiliated with Hillary Clinton's server
pretty substantial evidence that we gave
it to the FBI no evidence that it was
done anything was follow
so did they ever get back to you about
it no they never got back to us but also
call me you know call me is the best
witness here because he said well you
know we didn't have any evidence that
the her server was classified which
wasn't necessarily true but he admitted
that look they could have done it
without us knowing about it we'd never
know about it because they could have
covered their tracks so no one's ruled
out that her server has been compromised
in fact Comey said we just assumed it
had been compromised and sadly we've
sued this administration for its failure
do a damage assessment caused by her
leaving classified information on the
public equivalent of the internet
equivalent of a public park bench and
they fight us on this they said it
wasn't serious enough to warrant a
damage assessment look the deep state
doesn't want to do a damage assessment
they don't want to grapple with this
because to do so would undermine the
fiction that what Hillary did cause no
damage and deserve no prosecution I
think you could take Hillary out of the
equation and still be appalled by it as
the Chinese military hacking into the
personal accounts of high American
officials yes they are let's find out
the details tom Fitton I hope you do
find out the details I hope you bring
them here thank